in Toronto toasty in Toronto or you
could call it celebs singing for their
supper
Scarlett Matthew Reese and Jennifer
glammed it up on the red carpet for the
premiere of their new animated musical
sing but on screen well for starters
Matthews a koala and Scarlett well she's
a punk rock porcupine and you're pretty
rock and roll punk not something that
we're totally used to see anyway I know
what she really sounds like she's sort
of just like loud and proud like a
primal scream therapy they call me maybe
that's what the Koala sings the next
show is gonna be drumroll please a
singing competition oh no I was hot
stuff in the house for about three solid
weeks after they saw this there's a
selfish reason mind doing these things
about five years to come came number one
for a few weeks
[ __ ] so after three weeks it kind of
tails off though yeah they're looking
for another night they'll see it again
tonight maybe my status will pop back up
announce what it's all about
Matthews always at the top of our list
shows Reese
especially after seeing her late-night
date pick with her husband but Reese as
a pig well I'm having a hard time with
that Norman would you please tell them
what a good singer I am
yes a paper well you want to kind of
like bulk out the tombs at home with
them for the kids and zap embarrass them
as terribly when I try to sing Drake
song